i don't think there's anything funnier
um
than a hairpiece right i don't think
there's anything
funnier than thinking of a guy taking
his his hair piece off and putting on a
statue next to his bed
and laying his self down to sleep i just
can't imagine
there's a couple of things one how hot
it is
i just would feel like it's wearing like
a woolen hat
all the time it's like that you're just
feeling your your scalp being sweaty
and then also god forbid if you're
single
and you're wearing a piece and you meet
some woman and you have feelings and you
can't have any secrets
at what point do you [ __ ] lift that
thing off
dude bill it happened to my father my
father
married my stepmom is still married to
this day had no idea
it was three weeks after they were
married she said i have something to
confess to you and she pulled her hair
off and she has a wig she's got a piece
she's got a piece i used to put her wig
on when i was a little kid and make
and do jump shots and call myself
grandma mock is what larry johnson can
write
she had one she pulled her hair off yeah
dude i'm telling you
nobody nobody knew and then i remember
my uncle my uncle who's dead now
you know i was [ __ ] horrible thing
but he just would do these things for
laughs because he's a psychopath
but i pull and it was horrible to even
think about this now but as an adult but
when i was a kid i was just doing my
uncle said to do
i pulled her wig off on thanksgiving
dinner and ran down the block with it
that she's like a pioneer for women you
told me to do that
it'll be funny it'll be funny what did
she oh she was mortified
mortified and you know was had you know
resentment towards me for
years that's just recently you know
opened up to kindness and love
since i had my kid now she's happy and
she forgot about it but i was
i didn't know i was a little kid i was
being told what to do she's got to be
some sort of pioneer for women
i didn't even know women would could
have a hair piece yeah and it's a nice
thing it's a nice it's
sometimes you know my mom when they
would get an argument she'd bring it up
you know
yeah she's just [ __ ] make little
jokes about your mom's always got that
over here yeah oh it's brutal yeah
yeah that's why you can't you can't do
it you just kind of you gotta just
shave the head get [ __ ] for two weeks
and then people can't remember what you
look like with hair
and then it's over but you start you
know walking around [ __ ]
the skeleton's not even in the closet
sitting when did you
when did you just shave it bill how old
were you when you just shaved the head
how far back was the hair was the
hairline going how
how much was it fat joe's song lean back
before we like you know what let me just
give in to this
well that's a hip-hop reference so i
don't i remember that song uh
no i was losing it in the back so i
still have it in the front i don't have
it here so
so why don't you just go with the woody
allen with the little landing saucer
you could put a yamaka over it maybe
because i think he already has it he's
kind of done that look
true you look good now dude you look
like a [ __ ] emotional hitler stash i
mean you know
you got the right face for it i mean
what the [ __ ] i mean certain people just
you know i i don't want to but with that
guy's baggage i don't need to be right
bro same haircut
but if you you do have a nice round head
like
so it works out nice you look good
you're one of those guys who looked good
ball
but if you didn't if i didn't if i went
bald and my head wasn't as round as
yours i would try a piece
i would try
is they bring in reinforcements as
they're going
so now they like vacuum them out dude i
know guys who back in the day
the option there was before when i was a
real little kid you had those awful like
ant legs that literally you'd look at
them and you saw like that
dot they were [ __ ] horrible and then
um then they came up with a new thing
where they they would cut like a uh
like an eighth and slice out of the back
of your head
and then they would lay it on the
[ __ ] table
they'd stitch you back up this way and
then they would drop them in like that
not even knowing if they were gonna work
or not so that you'll see guys my age
still you'll see they have the smiley
face scar on the back of their head
that's from a transplant that didn't
take but now
you guys you spoiled millennials
they can just vacuum them out in the
back
no scar and then drop them in and you're
good to go
and uh you know we're in show business
we've definitely seen people losing a
battle and all of a sudden
in the fourth quarter they came back and
won and won big um
and it looks great too i'm just uh
i'm just not into it like i guess i
could do that but um
i i i don't i like i guess if you if you
look like brad pitt i get why
doing it but like why would i do all of
that like i feel like if you look like
me
the more you look like a regular guy the
better chance you have
at getting work you know yeah like i'm
gonna get hair plugs at 52 and what be
the next [ __ ] heartthrob
i'm 52. it's [ __ ] over right it's
over either way so
did you did they did when
when you went into the role in the
appetite movie about pete
did they did they at some point want to
put a rug on you you just went with
with the bald look no no
if anything they were like what if we
grow it out i was gonna do that
um i kind of look at my head like a
blank slate
so like whatever whatever you want to do
with it i don't give a [ __ ]
but like i'm not going to uh you know
acting is one thing
all right but like you're in a movie
whatever you got to look a certain way
whatever you know
but like uh as far as my day-to-day
like i'm not dealing with gluing some
[ __ ] on my head
or taking some [ __ ] that's keeping my
hair going but it's crushing my liver
so i'll dye it like 58 with a nice
[ __ ] you know healthy head of hair
nice
you know like a damaged liver i don't
you're the best you ever looked you're
the best you ever looked
now you just guys just get the [ __ ]
facial hair with the
bald look that's your look because when
you're in your late 30s you had kind of
your hair was it was receding hell
you're wearing [ __ ] bell-bottom jeans
you were going out of here you're out of
your [ __ ] mind i was like this guy's
the funniest guy i've ever seen he looks
like a [ __ ] idiot
but why is he got stars on his shoulders
it was baggy clothes
and we all wore them and you wore them
too i know i'm just kidding i'm just i
could see
well i mean i i you know you give me
[ __ ] i give it give it back that's
that's the game
yeah dude i'll take all the [ __ ] we
really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to patreon.com
where things get really wild
[Music]